guys, it's getting really, really bad.
April and May were seemingly nothing when
it comes to Corona virus compared to what
it is we are increasingly facing right now.
We are seeing new corona virus records almost
daily.
And these are not the types of records you
want to be setting.
Remember that for the Trump administration,
we beat this thing in May.
It's over.
I mean, we're months past victory.
Now, it's true that other countries did almost
beat this thing.
They are reopening safely.
They've crushed their curve.
And life is looking more and more normal.
And it's true that parts of the U.S. are reopened
almost completely, but those parts of the
U.S. are seeing some of the worst outbreaks
in the world.
If Florida or Arizona were countries alone,
they would be some of the worst countries
in the world to be in.
From the standpoint of corona virus.
So let's just look at the data.
Florida yesterday set the all time high ever
for any single day new cases in any of the
50 U.S. states.
Florida had more than 15000 new cases yesterday.
This is way worse.
This is thousands more than even New York
had at the worst point in its outbreak.
I was what?
It's making global headlines.
How bad things are in Florida.
I was watching Argentinean news this morning
and they said breaking news.
The United States state of Florida set a record.
We've never seen anywhere.
Meanwhile, on Friday in the U.S., again, I've
been saying this type of thing for months
because it keeps getting worse.
The U.S. set the single day record for cases
with almost 72000 cases in one day.
There are now a record estimated one point
seventy five million active cases in the United
States, almost three and a half million cumulative
cases.
And then the deaths.
You know, we were hoping I was cautiously
optimistic that something different would
happen, that even though the cases started
spiking around June 19, that deaths would
not spike 20 days later.
But sadly, right on cue, 20 days after the
cases spiked, we saw last Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, deaths back up to the
750 to 1000 per day range.
And it is believed that those deaths are tied
to the cases from around June 20 to 25.
Early July was way worse in terms of cases.
And if indeed we're going to see the same
pattern, next week is going to be very, very
ugly.
So there are about three layers of disappointing.
That's not really the word.
Three layers of dismay here when it comes
to what's going on.
First, we know the administration failed.
They don't seem to care.
Trump is golfing.
He's not talking to Foushee.
I'll tell you about that later.
That's number one.
We know it could have gone better because
just about every other country did better.
The proof is there.
There's nothing unique about the you know,
they'll say, well, these other countries are
less free than the United States.
No, they're more smart.
South Korea ranks higher on the democracy
index than the United States.
When you hear the only reason South Korea
did what they did is because they they're
not free the way we are.
According to the democracy index, South Korea
is more free than the United States.
Second, we are in this situation partially
because of the administration.
Yeah, that's true.
But partially, we're in the situation.
We are because of governors and the people
in the states.
Now, that's on both sides.
What I mean by that is Trump failed.
That's the starting point.
In some states, governors and people took
things seriously.
I'm not you know, some people say I brag about
Massachusetts.
I'm privileged to live in a wealthy state
like Massachusetts.
Listen, I just know what's going on here.
You see masks everywhere.
Schools are closed almost all summer camps.
Other than some very specific, you know, physically
distant camps that are possible, utmost caution
here.
And in fact, people are getting worried that
we're doing too much by by letting restaurants
do indoor dining.
I don't think we should in other states.
People who think masks and vaccines are the
problem are sort of joining forces with ignorant
governors to let the situation run rampant.
So that's horrifying.
That's the second piece, which is that as
Trump failing aside, you have a dramatically
different population in different parts of
the country and different governors who have
handled this very differently.
And you can see it in the case numbers.
And the number three, of course, is that we've
done so little, but we're pretending like
it was just beyond our control.
That's a very disturbing attitude.
Just look at other countries.
We chose to handle this differently than other
countries.
Some states did it one way, some states that
another way.
But we're almost saying we're all out of ideas,
except we've done almost nothing.
And they're looking at reopening Disneyworld
when Florida got 15000 new.
Cases in a single day.
It's truly vile and all we can do is, you
know, one of the tough things for me has been
relinquishing, not relinquishing.
I never had control, but recognizing that
I just lack the control to really affect this
at the big picture.
All I can do is OK.
I've chosen to live in a state that I predicted
would handle things well, generally speaking.
And I'm lucky in that sense.
And I live in Massachusetts.
I can wear my mask.
I can be safe.
I can tell people what I think makes sense
to do.
I can't control everything.
I can't control the vaccines.
And that's a really tough thing right now
for people who see how we've gone wrong from
day one.
Tomorrow night, please join the David Pakman
Show, Third David Pakman Show Chess Tournament,
8:00 p.m. Eastern, Tuesday, July 14.
I will be playing.
Everybody can play register for free at David
Pakman dot com slash chess.
I will also livestream my participation.
And secondly, tomorrow, same day, Tuesday,
July 14.
We will do be doing a big one day membership
special.
We're trying to dig out of a 300 member hole
that happened on July 4th when a bunch of
20, 19 members had to cancel because of the
virus.
So we're going to try to dig out of that tomorrow
with a one day membership special.
If you want to be notified about it, very
easy.
Just go to David Pakman dot com and get on
my newsletter, get signed up for the newsletter.
You'll see where to type in your e-mail address.
On the right side of the Web site.
Tomorrow you'll get a beautiful e-mail from
me telling you how to take advantage of this
discount.
In the meantime, tell me how things are looking
in your state.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.